let's talk about uh your guys's movie
uncle tom too yeah what's uh what's it
about what's going on i saw the first
one
and uh i learned a lot about herman cain
and he was uh he was a badass that was
awesome
yeah
so you know uncle tom
one
we'll call it uncle
uh really
turned out to be kind of a conservatism
101.
you know i start i started the film just
out of a curiosity
of you know why black america when it
came to conservative black america
uh was treated in such a way and i think
around 2015 2016
uh during that
cultural climate
the hypocrisy was very real for me
in 2012 herman cain um
you know was running for president
and
you know i supported herman cain i
thought he was great and two years prior
to that you know or i'm sorry a couple
years prior to that
you know if you didn't support barack
obama you were a racist and so literally
like you know one
political cycle later a black man from
the south
from atlanta georgia runs for president
and
he was you know
a [ __ ] and uncle tom all the things the
media completely destroyed him and that
shocked me because at the time i'd never
seen the media talk about a black man
that way because by that time we were
already on eggshells
so that kind of started the the the
wanting to make the film
and then
as i started interviewing black
conservatives it kind of just opened up
this entire world to me
and i realized there was a lot of
diversity there was a lot of different
uh walks of life within the black
conservative movement and on that
journey i met chad jackson who was one
of the people i interviewed for the film
and he actually became the main
subject of of the first film and during
that time um you know we became pretty
close friends
and when the film released and it was
you know we had some success and it was
very well received and
we were riding the wave of that
um i realized that there was more work
to be done there was a there was more
story to tell and so i asked chad
to come on board with me
and um
so
give us a synopsis on the first one then
tell us about the first the first one i
would say was conservatism 101. we
called it an oral history of the
american black conservatives basically
just establishing the fact that not all
black people are far-left democrats that
not all black people hate america that
not all black people view themselves as
victims in america
and i kind of think that
uh
i would imagine
the the stereotype i guess of the black
community in the church is that they're
more conservative outright but for some
reason keep voting with democrats they
are and i think part two as we you know
part two gets more into the historical
lineage of
what happened to black america and
during during the process you know we
take it all the way back to marx
you know uh when our country was on fire
a couple years ago during the the blm
chaos
there was an interview that patrice
cullers you know slipped up and told the
world that she was a trained marxist
and so people sort of like well what
does that mean
and what is this world view that's got
my country on fire
so uncle tom two
goes to karl marx explains who he was
explains what he believed
and his ideology and how it made its way
into america
and
and how america had to be
um
transformed slowly gradually because of
our history because of our individual
spirit marxism didn't really work in
america it worked in the east it spread
like fire in the east but in the west it
marks marxism was harder to sell
well it's been gaining a foothold across
the board in a variety of fashions and
for america it's taken a little over 100
years to get where we are
and as we zoom into marxism
you find that black america was the
low-hanging fruit for that ideology to
take hold
and to
use black america as its tool for
destruction in our country yeah i like
so from our perspective and justin's 100
percent uh right
uh
for me
what uncle tom 2 does is it showcases
this era of black prosperity
that we're not
we're not
traditionally told about in the
mainstream media and when i say
mainstream media i'm talking about uh
organizations like npr which is
constantly putting out you know stories
of black america as they see it and it
it's constantly depicting black america
as being oppressed as being under the
thumb of the white man it's being
hated by this country but what we found
when we dug into you know to the
archives is that black america
was thriving
in the 1900s from the early 19 to the
mid 1900s
not
in spite of
the white south but in some cases with
the help of the white south and so what
we found is that race relations between
white and black in the south were
actually far more harmonious
than
kind of oppressive like we're constantly
told about and so we're able to show
these these beautiful
uh
photos and and just this footage of
things that are not just frankly talked
about in the mainstream media and to the
extent that they do talk about it
it's always kind of uh
tainted with this kind of of oppressive
message that is meant to
constantly remind black people that you
are oppressed this country hates you and
because this country hates you you need
to vote this way you need to think this
way you need to
in a sense be entitled and so
it's offering a different perspective if
you will
the film also shows how to the extent
that you have these so-called black
organizations like the naacp like black
lives matter like these organizations
that are all about blackness asserting
blackness when you lift up the veil when
you pull back the curtain what you find
behind these so-called black
organizations
are
white marxists yep and so
it's important to showcase that because
this whole like you know this whole
pejorative of uncle tom
it's meant to
silence individuals like herman cain
like larry elder like thomas soul
because if you listen to thomas soul if
you listen to larry elder if you listen
to alan west you'll find that these guys
actually know what the heck they're
talking about
and to the extent that people apply what
it is they're saying
they will be benefited not only as black
folks but as people in general
and so you don't want such a man to have
a kind of effect on the masses of people
let alone black people and so you want
to in a sense demonize them and
ostracize them
and make them look as a kind of parasite
amongst the masses of black people so
you're going to call them this
pejorative you know uncle tom [ __ ]
booklet or sell out so on and so forth
because you want to silence them so we
we demonstrate that to the extent that
these so-called black liberal activists
are using these pejoratives they
themselves
are having their puppet strings pulled
by who
white marxists and so at the end of the
day i don't care
whether ideology is coming from a white
person or black person i don't care
because race isn't that important to me
but to the extent that i can expose
that the people behind these so-called
black you know pro-black individuals are
actually white marxists once we can get
that out of the way then we can have a
conversation about what actually matters
and what actually matters is ideology
and what kind of manifestations does
ideology have on the way in which people
are actually living and whether or not
people are prospering or whether they're
constantly failing baltimore is an
example of how we're felling under
marxism
detroit is an example of how we're
actually felling under marxism outside
of chicago all these organizations are
i'm sorry cities are examples of how
we're felling under our marxism we went
your way we applied your policies we
applied what it is you're pushing what
it is you're selling and black people
are not being benefited by it and so
these are yeah these these uh woke
leftists
they're the same kind of people that
were pro-slavery they're the same kind
of people that just want the status quo
and they and they're hiding behind the
revolutionary ideas but but it's not the
case yeah there was a story like the
site where a teacher asked his students
how many of you
would have opposed slavery in the time
of the american civil war and all the
kids raised their hand he's like oh okay
so tell me something that you'll
publicly admit to supporting that's
deeply unpopular and you know incites
anger and hatred and they don't have
anything to say the point was that most
of these kids were just doing whatever
they thought would get them to fit in
and when you look at you know i remember
reading about frederick douglass and he
challenged americans to to live by the
standard of their own constitution the
words that they wrote and swear and
swear allegiance to will they uphold
that all men are created equal that
these rights exist for everybody
and then a bunch of got pissed off at
them a bunch of white racists those are
the people who are like don't you screw
with what i got
the left thinks that they're
revolutionaries but they're supporting
the corporations they're supporting the
fbi they're in the government and its
policies and its machine and they're
demonizing i'll give you an example
anti-fuzz the perfect example of this
this is who i think of overwhelmingly
white they know it they love wearing
masks because they don't want anyone to
realize it and i watched white antifa
scream at a black ice officer the n word
and i've personally witnessed
white antifa screaming the n-word at a
black proud boy
and i'm like those all of those antifa
they're all white every single one of
them and then over here on the proud boy
side like mexican guy and there's like a
filipino guy and there's a couple black
guys and there's a bunch of white guys
and i'm like isn't that so strange
that's the case there are people who
believe in individual liberties and
there are people who believe in just do
as the mob says or else yeah yeah you're
100 right and like that's like we depict
that in our film we talk about people
like saul alinsky we talk about who the
real kind of founder of black lives
matter is it is a white marxist like
people look at these you know three
black women and think like oh
um you know they started this
organization because of trayvon martin
and because of they're being fed up with
the police brutality that the police are
constantly
uh kind of dashing out against you know
black
um you know
black and you know individuals who can't
protect themselves when in reality like
no that's not the case at all
it is a white man who
subscribes to marxist ideology who is
training these people by his own
admission he says that i go after uh
women
black and latino women i train them to
be revolutionaries i train them to start
organizations like we depict that in
this film and so one of the things that
we set out to do in making uncle tom too
is we didn't want to in a sense
regurgitate the same old conservative
talking points we wanted to go deeper we
wanted to show people where this
ideology is based out of and so this
film in my in my opinion is superior to
uncle tom too is in that in the sense
that we take people deeper
to see like where all this comes from so
as to not be constantly intimidated by
whatever social justice movement comes
along in a given era so so you're trying
to tell me when joe biden said you're
not black if you don't vote for him that
he was wrong
well i think one of the things i'm most
proud about about part two and the work
that we've done is just really like
getting to the core of america like what
made america
uh what made america was our
our world view you know our our
christian ethic
and you know being a moral people you
know
and
if you look at the history of marxism in
this country their number one
goal was to demoralize this as a people
and if you just take black america just
as a microcosm of america if you look at
the footage that we show you in this
film
black america
was a very prosperous very
entrepreneurial spirit
very moral people very church going very
nuclear family like all those things
were were happening for black america in
the early 1900s
and when you what what the marxists were
able to do was slowly demoralize
black america and now we're seeing the
effect of america at large is just to
take our
um
our morals away from us and create chaos
you know with with the christian
worldview that america was built on you
had order you know there was a
foundation there was a foundation in god
and and that created a a set of rules a
set of set of
a way to do things a way to do life
and that has been the the goal and the
tactic to destroy our country is to
slowly chip away at those morals and
those values
and so i think in my opinion what we've
what we've put together in uncle tom too
really showcased that showcases how this
happened like no other film and i think
that you know what we're getting from
people that are watching it and writing
us
is that it really equips them it arms
them with the knowledge that they really
couldn't articulate themselves yeah it
gives them the ability to
um understand what they what they knew
but they couldn't articulate yeah and i
think that we've labored over this film
for the past two years to
you know because explaining marxism is
hard to do yeah it's very hard to do to
explain these ideas
you know the first film was much easier
to put together because conservatism is
pretty easy to explain
but marxism is rooted in deception so
it's hard to untangle that for people
and i feel people are are are expressing
expressing that uncle tom too is giving
them that uh confidence to talk about
these issues yeah in a nutshell like the
way that i'll explain it is like what
marxist understood tim
is that
to the extent that they wanted to
inject their ideology into the american
society they were having a very hard
time doing it because the culture that
existed in america was very antithetical
to the communist worldview
and so
um
the fact of the matter is that culture
like how does cultures persist cultures
persist generationally through children
uh you instill and then you know and
impart your culture to your children and
then they carry it on into the future
and so what the marxist resolve to do is
that if we can get into the to the uh to
the culture of the children
if we can in a sense uh cause them to
rebel against the adult generation
um to reject the culture of the adult
generation we can um in a sense inject
our culture in our society in our world
view into the youth to where
you know the trajectory of our country
is completely different and so when you
look at second wave feminism in the 60s
when you look at the hippie movement in
the 60s when you look at the free love
movement in the 60s when you look at the
civil rights movement when you look at
the black militant movement all of these
are rebellious to the adult generation
of the 60s and what they were able to do
was to demoralize a culture to where
they are rejecting the adult generation
and are adopting this kind of new world
view to the extent to where today
more young people under the age of 30
are embracing socialism than any other
youth generation before in this country
that goes to that goes to show that what
yuri besmanov talks about who was a
defective
who who defected from the kgb it goes to
show that what he talked about actually
played out the way that he described it
and so
yes this is something that has taken
place in our country uncle tom ii uh
describes it
uh in a very palatable way in a in a
sense in a way that no other film um
and that i've seen have been able to to
to break it down thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you